this week on the climate show can we
catch climate heating carbon dioxide
from places like this before it gets
into the atmosphere or even draw it down
once it's there
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
where we're all about trying to clean up
heavy Industries I've come to a cluster
of such businesses across North Wales
and the north west and this one behind
me is a cement plant which is planning
to take out the carbon dioxide before it
goes up into the air we'll also hear
about one project in Morocco that
believes growing algae in the desert can
help remove carbon that's already in the
air and tell you about why some people
are calling this charcoal-like substance
Black Gold
but first this is the problem an
industrial chimney this one emits about
one million tons of carbon dioxide every
year and it's attached to an energy from
waste plant the idea of carbon capture
and storage is that we could take that
carbon dioxide out of the smoke and
fumes compress it and then store it
safely but it is hugely expensive just
massive as a project and many people say
it'd be better to just not have those
dirty Industries in the future
everywhere you look here there are
polluting Industries chimney stacks and
refineries line the mersey Estuary as
far as the eye can see important to our
economy but damaging for our environment
that's why it's been chosen as the UK's
first carbon capture cluster known as
high net capturing CO2 before it's
released into the atmosphere
just over the way there you can just see
a power station David Parkin is the
project Progressive director working
with around 40 companies to capture
their CO2 why here so this Region's got
one of the biggest concentrations of
industrial emissions but we've also got
really important geology for being able
to store carbon emissions deep under the
seabed offshore is this not just an
excuse for dirty Industries to carry on
polluting now I disagree with that
because these are all Industries which
allow us to live our life every day
today so the energy from waste plant
where we are today that's Gathering
waste from all around the UK and that's
going to continue operating in the same
way for 40 years so being able to take
the conducts from dioxide from there and
store it responsibly is a really
important part of what we're about
the plan is to capture CO2 that's
currently being emitted by heavy
industry in the area
by capturing it from the chimney and
compressing it in tanks before storing
it in a depleted natural gas field
beneath Liverpool Bay
captcha has long been touted as a
solution for hard to Halt emissions but
despite big promises precious little has
actually been built
so what's the difference this time well
it's front and center of the
government's legally binding commitment
to reach Net Zero by 2050 and they've
committed 20 billion pounds for the
technology over the next two years it
will definitely happen this time the
legislative backdrop has changed we're
in a net zero world now we cannot not do
carbon capturing storage the
government's really serious and yet we
had some delays last year because of
political instability but we're right
back on track
this power station runs on rubbish one
grab can hold seven tons
but burning it does create a lot of
carbon dioxide
those Ducks take all of those blue gases
up our stack our lovely 100 meter stack
and currently we emit all of those to
the atmosphere including all the CO2
inside
down the bottom here we have the flu gas
ducts what we'll do is we'll divert all
the gases that currently run for those
for your gas ducts we Punch Out across
the road to the neighboring site you can
see in the background so everything
that's there gets demolished so all
those chimneys will go all those
chimneys will go in the near distance
new carbon capture facility goes in and
what we do we run the flue gases through
that facility we've got what's called an
amine solvent strips all the CO2 out of
those flue gases holds on to it then we
take that solvent somewhere else heat it
up and it releases the CO2 as a pure
stream which we then pipe out into the
Liverpool Bay and we store it underneath
the Liverpool Bay we're talking about
spending in the region of half a billion
pounds on a site that is going to take
up everything you can see between here
and the salt Works behind there so uh
it's going to be big infrastructure it's
about the same size again as actually
the energy recovery facility behind as
well
another big climate culprit is cement
responsible for five percent of all
emissions
pretty much the core ingredient for
cement calcium carbonate but to make it
into cement you need to separate the
carbon bit of that off and that combines
with oxygen to make carbon dioxide so
the emissions from this aren't just in
the heat they're in the very chemical
equation itself
this is pagewood works just over the
border into North Wales and they intend
to become Britain's first cement plant
not to emit carbon dioxide within five
years by also linking to high Net's
carbon capture Network
getting very familiar with galvanized
stairways today
so why have you brought me up here next
to this massive metal pipe so this is
the Kiln that is uh crucial for making
cement so this is where we heat the the
limestone in a very very hot temperature
gases in there can be up to 1800 degrees
and at the moment all the CO2 from both
the Heat and also the chemical reaction
where does that go
into the atmosphere through the tower on
the chimney Our intention is to to
capture 800 000 tons of CO2 which will
be 100 of our CO2 emissions from from
our page of cement works and we're
constructing a sort of 400 450 million
pounds carbon capture plant on the field
adjacent to our plant Works Our
intention is to have it operating
alongside our current cement works when
will you be able to look me in the eye
and say the creation of cement is not
contributing to global warming so at
this facility in pagewood I will be
happily to invite you back in 2027-28
where our carbon capture facility will
be operating and we'll be capturing 100
of our emissions so 800 000 tons a year
of CO2 from this facility it's a date
one of the criticisms of CCs is the huge
new industrial construction it needs
here they're reusing some infrastructure
of the past there's no point in
capturing carbon dioxide if you can't
store it somewhere safe Italian Energy
company any operates gas platforms just
offshore in Liverpool Bay we go to our
our site which is one of their gas
Fields is now empty so they're planning
to use that as the CO2 lockup has this
worked anywhere else in the world yes it
does in several places and it has worked
for safely and securely for for years
there are now currently about 42 million
tons of CO2 stored per year in the world
most of it in the in the United States
but there are also in Europe in Norway
for instance we are partner of one of
them which has been operating since 95.
I mean is this a kind of survival
technology absolutely not let's make it
clear we are now offering the
possibility of two other to third
parties who are emitting to decarbonize
their activity so what we're doing here
we are offering this as a as an
opportunity for economy in this place to
continue I suppose that's what concerns
some people they think that carbon
capturing storage is more about the
survival of dirty Industries than it is
about the survival of the planet
I think it is very much one of the
components for an essential component
like the intergovernmental panel for
climate change says is an essential
component for the for the continuation
of the activity and for maintaining the
global warming within the 1.5 degrees so
it is an essential part to continue the
activity
the products made by the companies in
this cluster glass cement even breakfast
cereals and crisps are likely to be in
demand for many years to come but
cleaning them up requires a whole new
and massive industry High Net's vision
is for carbon capture clusters to spread
across Britain and the world but
realizing that Vision comes with a huge
bill and after so many false starts and
so little infrastructure built many are
still questioning if it will ever happen
as we've seen there are plenty of
efforts going on to try and remove the
carbon dioxide from the chimneys of
heavy Industries to help them meet Net
Zero but this does nothing to remove the
carbon dioxide that's already in the
atmosphere and needs to come out take a
look at this graph here it shows the
rapid increase in the amount of carbon
measured in our air over the last 60
years directly warming our planet and
changing our climate
so is there a way of reversing the
damage we've already done by pulling
some of that carbon dioxide back out of
the atmosphere one project in Morocco is
planning to use algae in the middle of
the desert
the world's oceans are home to Tiny
organisms called algae
in the right conditions they multiply in
the trillions creating huge blooms that
can be beautiful and extremely useful
well algae actually already removed
about half of all of the carbon removed
in the world algae removed more carbon
than forests what if you could recreate
what happens at Sea on land that's what
one startup is doing in the Moroccan
desert growing huge ponds of algae that
bloom constantly
they then dry it out and bury it
Underground
in their Hertfordshire lab brilliant
Planet burn the dried algae to test how
much carbon it stores it's so salty dry
and acidic they say it's effectively
mummified which is why it won't decay
burying this algae is like locking away
around 16 grams of carbon dioxide once
they build their first commercial site
brilliant Planet think that they can
bury enough of this to offset the yearly
emissions of around 20 000 people in the
UK
that even if it works at scale it will
take a long time to get there and we
will still need to urgently cut
emissions
in the meantime brilliant Planet will
sell its removals as a credit to
businesses that want to offset their own
pollution
but offsetting doesn't have the best
reputation
we are part of really a new group of
companies that are focusing on what we
would call very high integrity carbon
removal we can easily verify it measure
it so that when a company has emitted
carbon and we say we will remove the
same amount on your behalf we can be
very sure that we've actually done that
is there a danger that this is a
distraction from what we really need to
be doing which is cutting emissions
no the primary focus does need to be on
reducing emissions in the first place
but we are still going to have too much
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and for
those cases we will need carbon removal
many warn there is a real danger that
will rely too much on offset
ake to long to get right
scaling up any technology quickly is
risky and if you just scale scale scale
as fast as you possibly can you're
almost inevitably going to miss
something having said that we do need to
move really fast we are in a climate
emergency an emergency we found
ourselves in because every year
emissions are still going up making us
more desperate for new technologies like
this to work
Victoria Seabrook Sky News
another way of hoovering some of that
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere is
a very long way from the desert because
it involves plants and trees and it's
called biochar which is in effect a
climate-friendly version of charcoal and
as our science correspondent Thomas
Moore reports it could also help
increase the fertility of soil
so this is winter wheat it was drilled
back in October with a direct drill in
the soil of This research Farm in
leicestershire there is Black Gold
so what you got so this is biochart this
is spread last October it's similar to
barbecue charcoal but has a Priceless
quality when spread on fields the carbon
in the charred wood could be stored in
the ground for centuries to come biochar
could help agriculture reach Net Zero it
did sound too good to be true but like I
said we're open-minded we've kind of got
to take that opportunity to kind of show
that we are willing to change certainly
as an industry and as a business
wood releases carbon into the atmosphere
when it rots or Burns but heating it in
an oven purged of oxygen changes the
chemical structure locking up the carbon
the test for researchers is whether it
works on a large scale
this is now incredibly stable so far up
between my fingers it's hardly crumbling
we can grow the tree we capture the
carbon through its life cycle we add it
to the land we potentially get some
benefits to our crops and we're also
sequestering that carbon that's
important for helping combat climate
change adding biochilds really helped to
improve yields in particular it can do
that for example by improving the amount
of water the soil can hold but it can
also change the acidity of the soil so
it can increase it and that makes the
soil much more fertile and better for
the crops to grow in
but could there be even more magic to
making biochar biochar only contains a
third of all the material that was
originally in the wood but here in
Birmingham they're looking at the
two-thirds that would normally be wasted
and part of that is a liquid so at the
bottom here is oil that could be
upgraded to be used as a fuel in heating
boilers and ship engines on top is a
vinegar that could be used for weed
killer and a plant stimulator the idea
is to try and use every possible atom of
carbon that was originally in the trees
the air is kept out of the unit by the
airlock the material is taken up through
this Chute these pipes and heated
Chambers conceal a secret technique for
making biochar and capturing the
byproducts scientists at Aston
University said all adds up to make the
process economically viable we're trying
to catch everything which is in there
and make the maximum use of it so we get
the best use of the carbon and also the
best use of the products commercially
because they need to be sustainable
which means commercially sustainable so
they can also be scaled
seventy percent of Britain's land area
is used for farming if these large-scale
tests of biochar proof successful it is
a vast opportunity to unleash Nature's
carbon capture and Storage
Thomas Moore Sky News in leicestershire
there is a lot of excitement over carbon
capture and carbon removal but many
believe it's a dangerous distraction
from actually cleaning up our Industries
and not emitting that carbon dioxide in
the first place will get stuck into that
after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the show now earlier on
we're looking at the various ways of
reducing the amount of carbon dioxide in
our atmosphere by either capturing it
from the chimneys and then storing it
underground hopefully or actually
pulling it down with biochar or algae or
with me to discuss all these different
ideas is Chris littlecott from the
environmental Think Tank e3g Chris let's
start with high net that big project we
looked at in mersey's side they are
actually saying they're going to
retrofit carbon capture storage on
existing Industries at an eye-watering
cost I mean many many billions do you
think that will actually happen
uh I think we all need to see uh how the
treasury steps up here in the UK
um the the current approach that the UK
government is taking is much better than
the previous right attempts that they've
had but one of the stumbling blocks in
the past has been wherever the treasury
will put its hand into its pocket for
the scale of resources that have been
requested I mean they are using this
Italian oil and gas company any to do
the storage that's the plan I mean I I
you tell me what kind of record do any
have when it comes to climate change so
this is this is part of syndrome around
how do how do citizens and policy makers
respond to the different Industries and
actors in the space
any and many other oil and gas companies
have wonderful technical experience
you know putting CO2 underground is like
taking oil and gas out in Reverse so
with their engineering skills and their
geological knowledge they could really
be a helpful part of the solution but
companies like any also other British
companies like BP and and shell are
still on a very pro-gas trajectory in
their business cases and in their
advocacy towards governments so it's
great to see this company stepping up on
CCS but also they really do need to have
a comprehensive approach which is
reducing gas production in the first
place rather than continuing to promote
it and to ensure that the leopard does
genuinely change its spots does that
need enormous pressure from government
populations and not just in one country
oh absolutely I my sense is that we're
moving much more to a space where we're
going to have to talk about producer
responsibility it's not going to be
enough for oil and gas companies and
others to say oh well we'd love to do
this thing but it's expensive and
doesn't give us our returns please give
us a load of subsidies you know that
that puts all of the pain on on the
public purse we really need to see ways
that policy makers can get those oil and
gas companies to be making Investments
themselves because they have been yeah
you know so Central to the expansion of
production of fossil fuels in the first
place with water the water companies are
responsible for the waste after it's
been to our homes increasingly with
Goods that we throw away the producer
has responsibility
with fossil fuels they have no
responsibility we just let it waft into
the atmosphere you're saying that's got
to change oh absolutely it's been
incredibly easy and cheap for CO2 to be
emitted to the atmosphere putting CO2
back underground is really difficult and
expensive we can do it it's within the
bounds of our technical knowledge as a
as a species and as a set of companies
that we have operating but they actually
have to be forced to a point to make
those decisions to invest and make this
happen and if they prefer to do
something better and clean up that's
fine but let's not let them continue to
Kick the Can down the road I mean I've
been reporting on CCS for 20 years plus
but very little of it is still actually
there so this idea about hiding behind
an idea does have some validity yes
where CCS started was very much around
power sector but we can already go back
to 2009 here in the UK where Ed miliband
said okay no new coal power plants
without ccs and that really called The
Bluff of of utility companies and others
who were talking about future CCS but as
an excuse to build a new generation of
coal power stations and actually by
forcing companies and project developers
to really seriously think about wherever
they were going to take on the
difficulty and the expense of ccs
we've then seen the outcome is that
they've actually built Renewables
because they're better cleaner cheaper
and quicker should we just say
CCs is a dangerous distraction and we
can get away without it can we reach Net
Zero without it I I think that would be
unwise not only in terms of the
technology tools that we need at our
disposal in order to get to Net Zero and
can really drive that decarbonization
agenda but also about how do we force
these decisions and and having available
Technologies doesn't mean that those
Technologies themselves will be be used
but they can be overtaken by something
better if if we don't change the frame
of the argument then when then we're
going to let companies off the hook and
they will carry on as business as usual
thanks very much because such a
fascinating issue we're going to move
away from carbon capture now last week
we were looking at bees and their role
in pollination and particularly studies
that show we may have so many honeybees
they're affecting other pollinators well
new research has shown the extraordinary
importance of moths when it comes to
pollinating especially at night
[Music]
so if you think of pollinators you
probably got in mind bees because we all
know that we need to save the bees and
there's a big pollinator collapse
happening but what we've discovered with
our research is that actually the
nighttime pollinators moths are also
really important
there are traps to look at how often
Moss we're visiting flowers and what
we're amazed to find is that actually
although more pollination is done during
the day that's largely because there's
more time available and at night the
moths are really busy doing that work
now in the UK and further afield many of
our moths are declining and facing
various threats
[Music]
but there is still so much that we can
all be doing to help support moths by
providing important food sources and
habitats for them throughout the year
Bramble is often looked down on it as a
bit of a pest but it can provide a
really important source of nectar and
pollen throughout the summer
if we can allow patches of Bramble to
flourish it in our Parks our Gardens our
road virgins and hedgerows we can really
provide huge benefits for our marvelous
moths
so above all love you moths
[Music]
well that is it for now but don't forget
you can get your fix of all the
environmental news you want by looking
at the Sky News website or app or you
can scan the QR code that is on your
screen right now
next week I'll be looking at the
Resurgence of European sleeper trains
and even riding those romantic midnight
rails myself
[Music]